well we're young is directed and written
by Noah Baumbach and stars Ben Stiller
Naomi Watts Adam driver Amanda Seyfried
and Charles Grodin how awesome is that
to see him back again this movie is
about a 40-something couple played by
Stiller and Watts who meet a younger
couple driver inside ffred and they
start hanging out together because
Stiller plays a documentarian
and Adam driver is a younger
documentarian who's trying to figure out
his way throughout the business and
Stiller kind of his giving him advice
the older couple is inspired by their
younger viewpoint of life and a younger
couple is inspired by their older
viewpoint of life and they both start
influencing one another in various ways
but the emotional core of this movie is
really about how different generations
of people look at things like technology
friendship and of course life now I've
never really loved him Noah Baumbach
movie I thought greenberg was okay but
I've never really sat down and loved one
of his films I adored this movie it's
filled with characters that are so well
written and so well realized through the
performances and through the dialog and
you really start to get into their lives
and you can also kind of relate to it a
little bit it's a comedy for adults this
isn't your typical Ben Stiller comedy
this is by far his best movie since
Tropic Thunder I think it's one of his
best characters too because he plays
this documentarian who's tried for years
and years and years to make a film that
matters and what he sees an atom drivers
character who's also striving for that
same type of success as someone who had
half of his age is already more
successful than he is and that creates
some problems in some situations that
get really entertaining now an average
comedy might take those situations and
really play them for laughs but this
movie actually knows when to get
dramatic and it also knows when not to
push the dramedy aspect too much cuz we
all know there's this thing that those
heartwarming comedies try to do where
you laugh a lot there's fart and poop
jokes and then all of a sudden someone's
crying and it gets all serious and we're
supposed to care this movie wasn't like
that because throughout the whole movie
there's this great feel of realism to it
all it always treats its characters with
respect and it treats the audience with
respect as well because there are plenty
of moments throughout this movie where
you see characters do something and
you're like something's some ain't right
there and they never dwell on it they
never focus on it they leave it sort of
in your mind
like is that something that just
happened is is that really gonna be an
issue and then later throughout the film
you start to see why certain things
happen and it all builds to a great
ending that I loved I mean it actually
has quite a bit of thought-provoking
elements to it
Stiller was fantastic in this movie it
was like a cross between his character
in flirting with disaster and his
character and meet the parents except
more grounded and I loved Adam a driver
and a man decipher it and Naomi Watts
was actually really funny especially
when she has to take this hip hop
dancing class the dialogue is all well
realized these are real fleshed out
living breathing characters that we can
actually believe are real people and it
also has a fantastic soundtrack from
music of today as well as classics from
the 80s while we're young really
surprised me with its truly hilarious
dialogue it's well realized characters
and a lot of messages about how
technology might be taking over and how
the younger generation views technology
and how the older generation views it
particularly a great scene where they're
trying to remember something they can't
seem to get a grasp on someone says hey
let's google it and then they go no no
no wait wait let's just try to remember
it for real I love this movie and I'm
gonna give while we're young and a -
guys if you get a chance to see this
movie I strongly recommend it I'd like
to know what you think of it if you did
see it also big news I get to go to the
Star Wars celebration in Anaheim
California starting this Thursday I'm
gonna do my best to make that JJ Abrams
panel where they hopefully fingers
crossed revealed the first full trailer
as well as the first real poster I'm
gonna get a review and a description of
that trailer up for you guys I can't
wait to go and other things like Mark
Hamill is gonna be there and Carrie
Fisher and I wonder if there'll be any
stormtroopers there I mean that would be
really cool
hey man what's going on I've set you
down right there okay that was a little
weird guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck man
eyes